all right
citizens of the reject Nation Greg here
today
you know first off here's what I want to
say
I want to say thank you to all who have
supported us over the years the months
weeks days if it was just today this is
your first video with us as a weird
first video because not normally what we
do but uh Hey here welcome welcome
anyway
um yeah it's been a long time since I've
done a video like this on the channel
talking about this platform and a not so
positive way because I wanted to say
thank you up front because I'm I I am
very much grateful for what this
platform has offered my life in general
like is changed my life for the better
and so many ways and I'm aware that I'm
in a very fortunate position
so you know like I I it's been a long
time since I've publicly decided to say
something about some of the the faultier
parts of this platform but something
happened this morning that sort of just
reached a Tipping Point because like
even though it's been a while since I've
said something publicly it's not like
there haven't been things compounding
since I last said something it's it's
been pretty much non-stop a lot of
things you might hear other you know
content creators talking about we have
most certainly been dealing with the age
restrictions wow that is through the
roof it is like
non-stop this platform is so much more
sensitive than it once was and yeah like
even now I'm being very very like weary
about whatever be careful about what's
swear word I say because I don't want to
get age restricted over something so
silly uh but yeah like we deal with that
but there's something that happened
today that that isn't even as major but
it was just another thing to it was the
final found lay on the coffin for me
like I I just got a vent about something
that's going on with the with the
systems at play here because it just
doesn't feel equal it just doesn't feel
Fair it doesn't feel right
so here's the short version of what
happened this morning
now a couple days ago I heard the Avatar
way of Water trailer was coming out and
you know how we do we're gonna be
covering it and I'm very excited for
that movie so it came out like 5 30 in
the morning 5 30. call John tell them to
come over here gotta shoot it now we
have like a lot of videos here that
obviously will take many many hours to
to assemble like a lot of them do a
trailer reaction all right I'll give it
the benefit here is that they don't
really take as long as those other
videos it usually only takes me like an
hour to up to edit it and then you know
like an hour to finalize a thumbnail and
and finish uploading it right so like a
couple of hours on average so not not
that long okay but it's the video is not
about that that's not what I wanted to
talk about here's here's what it went on
okay I'll just be straightforward about
it when to upload the video also leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated
help us out here went to upload the
video and uh it was blocked it was
partially blocked but it was really
mainly blocked because it was 94 of the
world where it wouldn't be able to be
seen well that's most people all right
let me try another upload and in the
middle of re-editing the video and
messing with the trailer itself I I was
on YouTube and I saw that there were
other people who were able to get their
videos public with with no blocks or no
copyright claim issue and I was a little
bit surprised to see that and there was
one channel he you guys might know he's
a friend of mine they have a channel
where if there is even a copyright claim
just a copyright claim they're not going
to make that video public on their
Channel they'll more than likely move it
to their patreon account that's not
something we personally have adopted but
I know that about their Channel and when
I saw their video I was like wait a
minute wait a minute our video is way
more heavily manipulated than what their
video is right so I was like okay maybe
this is maybe a fluke for us let me just
try another edit cut to seven uploads
later I have now done every trick in the
book to the point where the trailer
reaction would be unwatchable but I was
getting desperate I had dropped the
opacity down to 90 percent I had put it
in a circle and it was extremely cropped
in not only that every frame of it was
completely flipped I had entirely
altered the audio around to the point
where you might not even really be able
to hear anything of what's really going
on in that trailer so I'm really messed
with it and I messed with the speed of
the trailer too every little trick in
the book I could to just try to get it
public by this point I'm like this is
this is freaking fair use this is
nowhere near like a re-upload of the
trailer now at this point still kept
getting blocked still keep getting
blocked
I didn't understand why I was like why
is Disney Fox blocking us exactly why
are they blocking us because they
normally Disney Fox is usually pretty
cool that's something that has sort of
copyright claim but a block is a
completely different story went to look
at the claimant the claimant was not
Disney or Fox the claimant is uh is
company called fox star Studios now from
the little bit of research that I could
do their involvement for what this movie
is like it just made no sense to me
they're able to issue a Content ID that
whoever uses any of this trailer all ad
Revenue goes to Fox star Studios doesn't
make any sense I've seen this happen
with other movie trailers before a
company might have the uh the slitherst
amount of involvement with the film
they're like but if anyone we could not
slap a consonant either so if anyone
used any of it we get all the ad revenue
for it and that's essentially what fox
star Studios is doing at least this is
my presumption from from the little bit
of research I did is that they're now
called star Studios and they're an
Indian company and I'm assuming they
handled the distribution for for Fox
films in India now if they were to claim
us for you know the the visibility in
India that would make sense to me if
they were to block us even to from being
seen in India that makes sense to me but
no that's not what they did and here's
how I know it's a bunch of [ __ ]
because I realized oh wait no we can now
make this public if we dispute the
copyright claim because normally what
happens is this if you dispute a
copyright claim you normally go into a
thing called escrow and what that means
is the claimants not YouTube the
claimant has 30 days to review your
claim and if they're like all right yeah
it's fine we'll let the claim go then
you can recoup that monetization earn
whatever earnings are on that video
within 30 to 90 days it can usually take
a while right so if we were able to go
into escrow that actually wouldn't be a
problem for me I know it's a problem for
others it wouldn't be a problem for me
because it at least gives us a fighting
chance of getting the uh the AdSense
earnings on that video but we couldn't
even go into escrow the only option
they'd left us with the because there's
a v one of the uploads I was able to
make public that is not the one that is
completely messed up so if you it's a
decent quality one all right but the
only option I left this with is you can
make this public but you're not going to
go into escrow and all money all
earnings from the ads will go directly
to Fox star Studios
and I said earlier that this is like a
compounding effect because it is another
case of [ __ ] content ID claimant
systems there's
this company out there well what they do
is they upload the audio of a trailer
and they put like a graphic over it just
some random graphic has nothing to do
with the movie but that allows them the
ability to create a Content ID that if
anyone uses any bit of that trailer any
little bit they can claim that they own
the audio to that all they're doing is
re-uploading the audio and they're able
to create a Content ID system and go we
own all all that so anything they do the
the ad Revenue should go to us I
remember PewDiePie was talking about
this now uh I mean I forgot how it might
have been a while ago someone was doing
that with his music and then they were
claiming his videos like his own
original music and they were able to
issue copyright claims onto him I know
that I can do this with other channels
that we get messages constantly for
example we cover Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania right we'll get some message
that some one other YouTube channel
channel that only uploads movie trailers
uploaded the Amman and the Lost
quantumania trailer and then they'll say
hey they uploaded this we think this
might be your video they're using
footage from do you want a copyright
claim them so I could theoretically
issue a copyright claim unlike movie
clips trailers sometimes and just be a
total dick about it and be like no we
own this even though I'm telling you
guys like it's obvious we don't own it
all we did was do a reaction to it but
the system is so faulty I in this
position can issue a copyright claim
I've had people doing this to us for
sometimes with our own videos it's the
most bizarre thing or it'll just
re-upload our video and they'll claim us
and now I know putting the word out
there is probably not going to help me
out at all I mean what does it matter oh
I got nothing left to do now but just
kind of explain to everyone how Shady
this system is that you can easily just
flat out steal from people with slow
like no effort at all it's so bizarre I
try sometimes I say something on Twitter
or whatever and maybe something a little
thing in a video I feel like their
systems to protect content creators just
it's so faulty that's the word that just
keeps coming to mind like we were one of
the channels I didn't even say anything
about it uh like I said something about
it on Twitter but it's anything about on
the channel uh we were one of the
channels that a couple weeks ago there
was a glitch on YouTube and a lot of
content creators ourselves included we
just lost all monetization for the the
entire Saturday that it occurred and I
remembered I had it's it was up to like
three in the morning working on a video
that I had scheduled to upload and of
course I didn't realize that we lost
monetization after the video had already
gone live via scheduling but that day
alone we got like 300 000 views that day
and not as actually close to like half a
million we had no monetization on it at
all like I don't expect YouTube to do
anything but let me just ask if they're
planning on doing something and of
course we're like yeah sorry it was a
glitch
I know a lot of other people dealt with
that too and I mean I know some people
who are fortunate enough to not be part
of that glitch that's just another
example of like that was an extremely
frustrating day when you're like up all
night working on a video and and then on
top of that just all the other videos
combined you get like almost half a
million views and and no monetization
YouTube's like [ __ ] happens it baffles
me that YouTube hasn't had a system in
place to some department or whatever you
know like I don't know how much I'm
really asking for here when I feel like
there's so many people way bigger than
us who [ __ ] about this who say that
this is a real problem to deal with with
the copyright claims and the age
restrictions and then they say they have
someone like the fact that it's the
claimant who's reviewing it and not
someone at YouTube is reviewing it is
wild to me sometimes it can be
ridiculous like just beat a claim from
Universal where they they had issued the
exact same claim to us the same time
stamp the same exact claim same wording
twice so it put us in a really weird
position where we had to fight the same
claim twice they were issued at the
exact same time like how can you issue
how can you do a double there's like
nothing different about the claim but
they issued like a double on us
fortunately was able to beat it but
still the fact that we're putting like a
constant having to to fight it out with
these guys is insane to me that there's
not a department of place to help out
with this when it comes to these manual
reviewers of people who review the
videos for the age restrictions it
doesn't feel like there's actually
someone really doing it there's movies
and shows that we've covered we've
gotten age restrictions on and age
restrictions pretty much mean you're not
going to be monetized and on top of that
you're not even going to get like the
visibility so sometimes like the movie
reactions they can take so long to put
together they're age restricted so then
they're not even getting seen and that's
like that becomes the most disheartening
part of the whole process to me is man I
really wanted more people to see SEMA
everything everywhere all at once
reaction but they don't watch other
people's new reactions like the same
parts that apparently I made restricted
for I'm seeing in this person's video
and they're not age restricted so I
don't understand what the guideline
system is for these manual reviewers I'm
very much vexed by this whole situation
because you know like my I think a big
part of why I I didn't want to keep
doing videos about it when I feel like
every month I can sort of do a video
about it you know one thing that you'll
find uh any any any like person who
makes their living off of YouTube in
some way will attest that the most
common thing that you talk about with
other YouTubers is not we all sound like
a bunch of ungrateful bastards who oh so
much of us do we really do is that which
is mainly [ __ ] about YouTube about like
there's the new issue they've created or
the ongoing problem that still hasn't
fixed because our we our lives dependent
on this this platform that that's that's
the thing thing and a big part of our
job is to make sure that when the camera
rolls up we're just having a fun time
and we're having a good time we want
people to feel good when they're here I
didn't want to keep putting out the the
stressful part I do think though that
like talking about this is important and
it is something that
I know I'm not alone on going through
with this even with the situation with
the Avatar trailer to me it's just like
why is it that all these other people
are able to get their video not claimed
but some of us are getting claimed and
getting our videos blocked
how is that fair I'm not saying that
their videos should be blocked I'm
saying fox star Studios shouldn't be
doing this to anybody to begin with
nobody should if it's not freaking
Disney and fox I don't think fox star
Studios should have control over the
visibility around the world of whether
or not our video should be seen nor
should they be entitled to all the
monetization rights for the video so
yeah there's there's a lot of the the
same problems I've talked about before
are still ongoing and they've only
evolved in in newer ways that feel like
they they just
YouTube's always issuing stuff about
like wanting to protect its content
creators or whatever and and I I never
really get the sense that that's really
where the interest is at you know and I
feel like a lot of you guys pick up on
that too so yeah ah just another
another [ __ ] situation that uh I I
had to get off my chest because even
though today it feels like a smaller
issue compared to a lot of the other
ones we've dealt with that I just
haven't talked about
it was just push me over the edge to be
like this isn't fair
this is like this it's just not fair
it's not fair if we're not all in the
same boat together on this freaking
copyright claim situation then nobody
should be getting copyright claimed or
everyone should be in copyrighted it
should be one or the other and my belief
is fox star Studios shouldn't be
claiming anyone to begin with in that
regard their content ID should be set up
for for solely India if that's the case
but but for worldwide like come on what
a bunch of crap
so yeah that's uh
it's my rent for today
Jesus Christ
[Music]